つい2わー5
ほんとどこ行ったこんにちははじめ社長ですでーぶれー
ちょっとあしばらくサボってで全然やってなかったんですけども久しぶりにアニメとか
あ新型のベイビーネット見たらめっちゃかっこよくてキュッ
ちょっとチェックしちゃいましてちょっとまたベイベーレーダーちょっと言いてえと
思ったってちょっとこのやる気がすぐ出てきて最近のかっこいいんですよなんか
どんどんいかつくなってきてて目
着差ちょっとオサレな感じになってきててどうぞをちょっと復帰しようと思って米で
始めようと思って
そんな矢先に事件起きてしまった俺はああーーや
そんなすごい話じゃないですよねそうがすごい話じゃないんですけども僕からしたら
ええとなるくらいちょっとびっくりしたというかちょっと頃の中で
って感じだったんでちょっと聞いてくれ
その新型のベイブレード買おうと思ってそのベルトを張ったんですよ覆面で袋すっげー
プロ頃そうだかアニメに出てもすげーかっこよかったですよね
スプリガンレクイエムアニメの主人公のライバルが使ってレベルとなるんですけど
めっちゃかっこいいじゃないですか
僕赤とか黄色が好きなんでもうすごいわけでキラキラしててみて水右手の能力が融合を
一番強いやんっていうかもうなんかをいろいろ
て全部混ざっている最強のベビーで飲みたいな全機能を搭載っても一番柱や梁回転だの
うそすげーだからそんなに4パットに競ってこれ強いやというレベルを見つけたんで
すぐ買おうと思って買ったんですよ
でもねこれでも普通のお店だとなかなか売ってなくてこれもう amazon で買う
しかないなと思ってアマゾンで買いました amazon 組と結構高いんですよ
橙2300円くらいなんですけどそれのベストセラーですごい売れてってやっぱり人気
の商品だなって
思いますってかパークで強そうだから使いたいなとで買って届くの楽しみに待って待っ
て待ってようやく届いたわけなんですけどたこパパっていく中身は開けてみると
[音楽]
色近くにをそう a
遅思え泳い
待って待って待って待ってますねー
僕は赤色の赤 l のこのスプリガンべく言える普通ですが欲しかったのに
あけてみたらマック前田いいですか
おい何でたよさつけんなよ
って思ったんですけどこの中の神見てみるとこんなのが入ってますって超レアカラー
バージョンおめでとうございますこちらの商品はそれがでクリアミニ低確率で封入され
ている超レアカラーバージョンです
塩分元気でね聴いて聴いてる全然ベイブレードのこと何にも今知らないからわかんない
しこれどうやら
すげー激レアのそぼろやからバージョンのフィールドらしいでございます
つか何よいやーすごいなぁん
汗本当にベアらしいんですねちょっとプレ変えリアーナとかちょっと調べてみますか
puja ゲット当然ってかこのブラックなどが入っている確率は1/72あーじゅり
分の1ってあっと聞きながすごい高そうに見えるんですけども
単純に言うと72個買うと1個あたっている計算になります何 amazon でも4
コスプリ管でゲーム化をするとえっこ2,000円
300円じゃないなんて2300かける72165,000円
水ます玉田はスプリングへ向かって1個買ってあげてみたら
中杉ペリアの色違いのでベルトが当たってしまったみたいでございます
あれっ
弱水流に嬉しいです普通に嬉しいですし
な気になる普通の素プリがにくいません500円ぐらい打ってますねそういう
ネットとかねうん
[笑い]
うーん本当によく旅行なんですけどこのパーツだけ今値段見たんですけど大会
22,980円とか言ってました
ちょっともこれ割高だと思いますそんな所がないでしょ
でもまぁまぁまぁだいたい1万
平和を超えてますね amazon 打つないんだろう
ふーんだざっところに1個しかないんですけど14,000円で売られております
[音楽]
大切に所やまず大切でしょぜっており裏ねてかなんかすごいで運命もハンズました久し
ぶりに売らないんですけどなんかちょっと保存とかして飾っておく
量的なやつなのかな8使おう
を見るとて回ったか言いますからね
うん
ん
はっはっは
ス into は5号
[音楽]
第二がかっこいいなでもなんかねは回路が好きなんですけどあと真ん中バー解除別に
いいやって思ってきましたそれでもなんかね
2000円のもの買って届いて開けてみたらいつも4000円のものが入ってたって
いう自慢に戦の後です
シャーッ
[音楽]
使いづらいよ
me
ni
バッハ